rudy gave us one out of eight for three
mitchell mixes for three
mitchell is over six from three
stanley johnson runs into gopro he'll
get a three-point opportunity
you can't show the ball and you can't
give them any space get contact let's
lay it up lady in
i mean this is
you know denver could miss denver could
miss they're having trouble making
stanley though for he's asserting
himself here in the form seven minutes
to play
great there's having an embarrassing
loss in denver
battling utah stan's got it again
johnson from the free-throw line
again the last i think he's just reading
the defense that gobert sags back stops
and shoots the free throw lakers are
back up to 44
stanley johnson
modern day in high school
finds his way back to southern
california raises it again
just takes it off the drip uses the left
lays it in and gives the lakers a four
point lead his first
field goal of the game that's crazy
it's a recipe for disaster if you're
johnson underneath scores again and he
beat rudy gobert in the restricted area
against goldberg and get him to back off
enough and then just step through and
score was a long time on the bench for
westbrook
[Applause]
good ball throws it up can't score
he tipped it up and in hands are high he
has to throw a bounce let's get another
look at
reeves what a tip in with the
left hand the fingertips that's
literally that's just great hustle by
austin reeves he's got bob donovan with
eight to shoot over bob donovich
rebounds johnson toes the line and gives
the lakers an extra 14.
stanley controls finds bradley
yes
yes sir there's a little exception to
that
it was just a great play by stanley
johnson offensive rebound
then he gets the pass back from lebron
and spots the man opening the corner and
gets the assist to avery bradley that's
just
can't say enough about that play from
stanley johnson
bravery bradley nine points
hit his second three and a smart foul
that he just committed on on gobert
because gobert getting ready to dunk
absolutely